this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
cart rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host ken
coleman ramsey personality and host of
the ken coleman show is my co-host today
as we answer your questions about your
life and your money the ken coleman show
is all about your career all about
getting in a job and in a career field
that you love doing work that matters
that you're good at and where you can
actually show up and be glad for the
time you spend at work and the way to
maximize it so you've got career
questions
i need a job questions well ken is here
to help with that and he's going to
comment on everything we do here today
as well so we're uh welcoming you in the
phone number is triple eight eight two
five five
two two five so can this from forbes car
shoppers
on limited budgets can't get a break the
average transaction price for a new
vehicle is expected to rise to a record
38
255 dollars in may according to jd power
sending many consumers looking for
bargains on used car lots no such luck
the combination of high demand and high
wholesale prices dealers pay to acquire
inventory has led to record high prices
for
used cars
toby russell co-ceo at
onlineusedvehiclemarketplaceshift.com
told forbes
the surge in used vehicle demand is
causing bizarre bizarre behavior in the
form of used car prices appreciating
given the strong demand for consumers
the tight supply situation that seems
likely that used vehicle prices already
at all time highs will continue to rise
there's a silver lining for those
looking to trade in their current
vehicles
vehicles demand such as pickup trucks
crossovers suvs are bringing top dollar
and the amount paid
on a site right now is increasing 15 to
20 percent in some cases 30 percent over
the last year for the same used car
first time in history used cars have
gone up
in value well they haven't over a period
of a year but that same exact vehicle
all caused by the covet economic
disruption yep uh people in factories
not making cars that's right also i read
about people not in factories making
cars
that's right well i also saw that be
because travel was literally almost
suspended
that rental car companies are a big
source of used cars as well because
they'll order cars from manufacturers
they'll rent them to folks like us and
then
after a certain point they'll sell them
back and that becomes a part of the used
car inventory as well so you have two
things manufacturing as a whole also
orders from
carmel companies so it's really
fascinating but i will tell you this i'm
in the market
uh i can't even believe i'm saying this
dave my oldest is going to be 16 in
november so i'm already beginning to
look just to see is there something
right now that i could jump on and get
it get a great deal put it in the garage
and for him and so i've been looking a
lot just uh direct to consumer uh
facebook marketplace is a great option
there there's all kinds of auto trader
and so outside the dealer i still see in
fact i spent a good time this weekend a
good amount of time looking there still
are great deals if you're buying
directly
from someone else but to the dealers
there's no question the prices are up i
see that yeah
and so
the other thing that's happened was um i
bought a used car last week
and i bought it at market it didn't pay
it was not up um took a little work
though yeah and i actually looked at the
new version of that car
and uh there's such a shortage on it
that dealers are charging 20 000 over
sticker
for that particular car
and uh now it's an expensive car but
they're they're adding a premium on it
on a on a new car because they they gave
me a quote on the new one and i'm like
uh dude i buy it invoice and the guy's
like not today you don't right and not
right now you don't he goes there
across town this same brand is selling
these for twenty thousand over sticker
he said well i'll tell you a sticker and
i went i think we're gonna go used so i
bought a used car and so uh but it's uh
uh
man i mean it the this disruption
and it's just like the new housing like
the new housing market is screwed up
and so it's screwing up the used housing
market and then people go cray-cray
and they get the chasing stuff and get
the fever and it's like oh god oh god
i'm not gonna be able to get what i want
it's like a little kid on the cereal
aisle having a hissy fit
and then they over pay for stuff
and so um yeah i used vehicles uh
there's a shortage
and um
definitely
and there's a shortage for uh uh
the new because there's a shortage on
new because the factories were not
dialed up and it's gonna take a little
while for it to catch up it looks like
it's going to take a little while for
lumber supply demand to catch up right
now lumber's selling for more than gold
it's unbelievable it's true and drywall
i've talked to a builder friend of mine
brought sheets of drywall to explode
everything plywood the glue going into
plywood there's a shortage on they're
saying it's going to go up 4x before it
comes back down but it'll come back down
and these used cars will as well yeah so
plenty but the good news is if you're
out there and you like just decided i'm
going to get out of debt
and you're like i've got to get rid of
this really stinking overpriced i bought
too much car yeah you know i got a 30
000 car you know 28 000 or oh 32 000 on
it this is a great time it really is it
really is a great time to move down in
car uh it's a great time to get rid of a
car yeah that you that you're trapped in
so that's the good news i'm curious to
know what the trading values how much
it's gone up because traditionally
that's way way lower than what you can
get if you sell it yourself yeah demands
you know the other parts of this article
which i didn't read uh but the man
mannheim is the largest wholesaler the
auction houses that wholesale to the
dealers and um they're seeing across the
board about a 10 to a 15 bump wow and uh
so that's that's and then of course
that's of a used car going across the
dealer auction dealer puts that back on
his lot
and um you know they're not in the
business to lose money so they're gonna
be marking it up that much so we're
seeing this uh the the i i
knew there were gonna be
shortages because of covid we talked
about that at this time last year
because these factories all just shut
down
and it took them forever
to come back um and you knew there were
going to be shortages but what i didn't
for some reason i didn't i was dumb i
should have been obvious i did not see
the price increases as a result because
it creates a shortage and drives prices
up simple supply demand curve stuff and
you know you get into that
and uh but you're right the um
the
uh
rental car companies hertz it owns
dollar that sponsors the dollar car
rental studio so we've had discussions
with them i didn't realize until we were
sponsoring them and we were actually
talking to them at this time last year
because no one's renting cars
and so they're all screwed they're all
going into bankruptcy they're all you
know right on the teetering on the edge
and what they did was they just sold off
half of their inventory
liquidated these used cars like crazy
they dumped them on the market well now
the market's gone the other way and now
they can't get the new cars
and so it's gone back the other way so
they a lot of rental car companies have
a shortage of inventory to rent to you
oh we see that all the time it's not
unusual very normal it really is
interesting and hertz is the third
largest car dealer in america massive
yeah that's amazing well you know it's
like you said dave it's like we had all
this extra supply but we burned through
it and now the factories are trying to
catch back up so it's going to be this
way for a while i created a new uh thing
as you were talking msrp
now it's iii it is what it is
you like that so don't buy a new car
anyways we don't tell you to buy a new
car unless you unless you've got it and
then some but now it's the time to stay
away yeah yeah just just
here's a plan
not right now yeah i don't i don't need
it that bad don't need it that bad this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author of the book the
proximity principle is my co-host today
as we talk about your life and your
money the phone number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five joel is
in dallas hi joel how are you
dave i'm doing great sir uh good
afternoon to you and ken i want to say
thank you so much for uh what you guys
do every day it's important to a lot of
folks out here that are trying to better
their lives and figure stuff out so
thank you well thank you sir how can we
help today so here's my question we're
on baby step four and um we i've got a
401k question the company that i work
for
does a very generous uh match
every year it's a profit sharing it's
not actually a match and it can range
between 10 and 15
of my total salary not sure what it's
going to be every year it's not set in
stone kind of fluctuates
right now we are putting 15 into the
401k the traditional 401k every year
and have been for the last three or four
years so we're looking good but my
question is this do i need to be
according to the baby steps do i need to
be putting that much in
given what my company is also
contributing and then second part is do
i need to be looking at
adding the 401k roth option in as well
in addition to or separate well if you
change your 401k will either be
traditional or it will be roth and it's
better for it to be roth and so i would
change it to roth from this point
forward now the matching portion that
they give you cannot be roth it will be
traditional
by law okay
the matching portion does not affect our
baby step four baby step four is you
put in 15 of your income
if you get gravy on the biscuit extra
gravy on the biscuit caught a match
that's just that much more wealth you'll
have but i don't depend on them at all
the point of the baby steps is you are
controlling your destiny
and so you put in 15 if they match if
you have a match you certainly take that
match
and so matches better than roth is
better than traditional that's the order
of attack
the rock paper scissors so to speak
and um so yeah switch it to a roth and
you put in 15 which it sounds like you
are and you just continue to do that
can so the in the old days the um like
when i first started this show 30 years
ago
uh
still at that time
a lot of companies had the traditional
pension plans now 78 of companies have
done away with pension plans they don't
have them anymore
and so
it's pretty much a roth
or a 401k
or an ira you're going to do your own
thing
and you're going to do it through your
company and the that's the bad news the
good news is a lot of them match
over 70 percent of companies do match
because they don't do the pensions
anymore yeah
why did they pull that was it did it
come down to taxes for companies or is
it too much to manage why the shift from
i didn't know that number i wrote it
down because that was that was really
shocking to me that that many companies
aren't doing pension plans why would
they do away with them well they're
super expensive they're super regulated
to
manage pain in the blood to operate
right uh and because can you think about
it i mean you have a team member that
joins you at 40
at uh 60 they retire
and you now manage this pension for them
for the next 25 years yeah it's too much
time and money and so it just becomes
very cumbersome and with regulations on
them they didn't perform they don't
perform that well
they're not allowed to invest the way
that i would invest or the way i teach
people to invest so they don't make it
they don't make a good rate of return
and so
uh but it's bad for the individual
because now you the only way you have
money in your 401k is you have to put
money in the 401k it's good for the
individual though because the 401k is
yours yep and the pension is not if the
company goes broke it's an asset of
theirs you could lose the you know the
old story the mind the mind closed up
papa lost his pension that's right you
know and so because the the pension was
not his it was an asset on the books of
the mining company that went broke and
so they lost it
now that doesn't happen as much but with
the regulations and the insurance and
stuff we've got now but the union
mismanaged the pension and frittered it
away you know these are real stories
that have happened to real people
when it's a 401k the company goes broke
it doesn't touch your 401k because it's
not in their name it's in your name
you know accessing it with a broke
company with the hr department closed
down maybe a bit of a cumbersome thing
but the money is still there it didn't
leave
and so you you are controlling your own
destiny
you're responsible for it and that's
both a blessing and a curse that's right
because look just like it is when
everything that we're responsible for we
have to actually step up and
man up woman up and get her done
miranda is with us in charleston west
virginia hey miranda how are you
great how are you doing better than i
deserve how can we help
so my husband and i were working on um
baby step two we're going to zell
intense and we're trying to we're
looking at our numbers
trying to figure out how to
get our payments to go down
um
we have a car it's a ford cmax a 2004
and
kelley blue book has offered us ten
thousand dollars
and we owe 21 000 on it and that loan
right now has a 5.9
interest rate good lord
yeah so what is this car really worth
is kelly blue look shooting you that low
are you financing negative equity from
the last deal into this one
um no uh we owed 21 000 on it and
they're offering us 10 000. i know what
they're all i heard that part that's
ridiculous
so i'm guessing the car is worth 15 and
they're trying to steal it from you
probably
um it's in pretty good condition it's
2004. it's elec it's a hybrid
did you finance negative equity were you
in the hole when you wrote trade it in
yes okay so some of this hole is from
the other car
okay so you need to do some more
research and find out what the car is
really worth because
uh if a wholesaler kelly i didn't even
know kelly blue would bought cars but if
they do i'm sure they do and um
if i host they're buying it at wholesale
because they're going to resell it for a
profit which means that you put it on
the market we're just talking about that
coming into the show you're going to put
the thing on the market for full value
so check
kellybluebook.com not counting this and
just look up of the value do an
appraisal on the car you can go to
edmunds.com as well it means car guide
and pull up and say private sale if i
put the thing on facebook marketplace or
neighborhood marketplace or whatever
these things are that are out there and
you know uh craigslist and people still
do that and so on uh i don't know is
craig dead he could be dead but um
uh but anyway that that's uh um
you know so along along those lines you
going to sell the thing trader i know
trader.com you can use and i sell it
direct like ken's out there looking for
a car for his son he talked about that a
minute ago
and so yeah you're going to probably
find that car's worth
13 15 something like that it's probably
not worth 10.
10 sounds insanely yeah yeah i'd have to
know the mileage on that but you can get
a really good value on that very easily
multiple sites and you could you could
really hone in on the condition of the
car
and i think you get the most as you
possibly can for that because right now
as we said an opening segment people are
your car is competing against the
dealers who are selling used cars at a
premium so if you sell it actually at
market value you're going to be very
competitive a lot more attractive than
there's a shortage so yeah definitely
definitely make sure you have your
values right so miranda a good rule of
thumb is this
in a negotiation
which selling a car is a negotiation
buying a car's negotiation
he with the most information
wins
he with the most patience
wins
and he or she with the most options wins
i don't need to sell i got lots of
options i don't have to sell it i'm not
desperate okay so you got walk away
power
you find out every detail about what
every car like that at every site is
selling for and you become a dead gum
expert on the used car market around
that particular car information he with
the most information and then you just
slow your butt down
you don't get the fever
people get emotionally
like like they have people when they
sell stuff they just they get
emotionally like it's already gone in
their minds and so now they have to give
it away
no no just just plan on keeping it a
while
and be a little hard to get along with
when you're selling it you know come on
now
maximize this asset you need the money
you're broke
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is the ramsey show
i'm dave ramsey mikel is with us in
seattle hi michelle how are you
i'm good how are you guys better than i
deserve what's up well um i have a
question that i i feel like is probably
splitting here but i wanted to know what
you would advise we currently have a
20-year fixed-rate mortgage and i'm
wondering if we should finance down to a
15.
not for that reason only if you get a
better interest rate because if you take
a 20 and you calculate what the 15
payment is and you just pay that much
extra it'll pay off magically in 15.
sure so you don't have to refinance to
do that
so what is the interest rate currently
it's 375 and i talked to churchill and
they said they could get it down to 275.
okay what's your loan balance
uh 235. okay so one percent saving is
and 2350 bucks a year right
and if it costs you five thousand
dollars to refinance you get your money
back in two years
if it costs you seven thousand dollars
refinance you get your money back in
three years
so you don't make any money until you
get your money back
okay so are you going to be in the house
a while
yeah for a long time we planned okay all
right i probably would refinance it and
while you're at it put it on a 15.
but you don't need to re if let's say
you had a 2-7 let's say you had a three
percent
20-year mortgage i would tell you just
sit on it and pay extra
okay you don't need to go to the
refinance cost to pay it off early
you just pay extra and it'll pay off
early
but you refinance you refinance if you
can save
not sending them as much money
as you used to
do you know as you used to send them and
so um
you know there's gonna send them 2 350
less per year
for the next many many years until you
pay the thing off one percent savings
per year yeah so i'm refinancing that if
you're staying
and while you're at it do it to a 15.
charlie's in los angeles hi charlie
welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave thank you so much for taking my
call really appreciate it what's up
i am a small business owner out in
california and it's been luckily a
pretty rapidly growing company over the
past six years and i'm dealing with an
employee of mine who is my general
manager i think has a bit of a spending
addiction
which is making me kind of wonder if i
need to do all the ideas from a raise or
if it's best just to let him go when
that time comes
if i can give you a bit of a background
on this gentleman he's in his mid-30s
three kids works full-time for me 80
hours a week he's a great asset to the
company and
he's in this management position for
just over a year
80 hours a week
um 40 hours a week my apologies oh i'm
on the bike yeah sorry 40 hours a week
okay um now the issue is that he left my
company before when he was a warehouse
packer he came back and he worked up to
his management role but since then he
has about a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars i estimate conservatively in
cars
and like automotive toys um he kind of
mentions and complains about money and
stuff but not really in like a i'm
expecting a raise type thing i try to
give him raises organically without him
asking to award good work what's he made
he did kind of
he makes 45k a year
okay
and he just kind of casually in
conversation asked me if he could start
leaving earlier
monday through friday to come in a bit
on saturdays so that he could work a
second job
and just because he has left the company
previously
i just kind of wonder you know i'm not
going to plan on letting him go but if
he does ultimately say that he wants to
leave should i
try to keep him around or focus on my
younger staff who are who have their
potential and don't have as much how
many times how many team members do you
have total
right now we have 15. okay cool okay
yeah the question i have for you charlie
is forget the finance issues
is this guy a great leader for you or at
least a good leader with tremendous
potential let's set aside just for a
moment your concerns about his spending
and him asking around about a raise
is he a quality team member that you
think
if he's healthy you could develop him
even further up
so the thing about my small company is
that it's all been a learning experience
kind of for all of us he didn't really
have any managerial experience but he's
been doing a great job of learning but
what i really value about him more than
anything else is that he cares about my
company treats it like it's his own and
i feel like does genuinely want to see
the company do well
well i got to tell you that right there
to me is one of the greatest
characteristics of somebody that they
care deeply about your company and so
he's he's unhealthy financially and uh i
i would sit down with him and have a
man-to-man but come at it not from a
judgmental standpoint to say hey here's
what's going on i don't have all the
facts here's what i think i know help me
fill in the blanks and here's why i'm
bringing this up i care about you
because you
care about this company you've done a
great job you've learned and you've
grown and you're mentioning some things
here and there why do you need more
money here's what a a development plan
might look like and here's how you'll
keep getting raises and share a vision
for him and see where he's at
financially and see if you can help him
and pour into him and take care listen
i'd get him financial peace i'd put him
through it and coach him up if he's
willing to do that show him how if he
gets his spending habits under control
how it will change his entire
life you know i'd be willing to have
that conversation if i were you because
of what you just said about this guy i
think he's worth investing in now i
think you got to have a point where you
get to where you say all right i've
invested and i've coached and and and
now it's up to him and if you feel like
it's too big of a divide he's not going
to get there and you feel like he can no
longer be the employee that you need
then you move on but i wouldn't try to
anticipate him leaving i think that's
managing and leading out of fear versus
being proactive
so when we're were doing entree
leadership
when we were doing entree leadership a
couple weeks ago out in dallas
um
[Music]
pat lencioni said there is no such thing
as
uh any kind of leadership except servant
leadership
and so if you're going to lead him then
you need to care enough to serve him
and how are you serving him uh you got
to sit down and go dude forty five
thousand dollar income hundred fifty
thousand dollars in toys you're doing
vouchy math here this doesn't work okay
you can't this doesn't work you know
you're not in congress you have to stop
this
for your sake
you can't win doing this and i love you
and i'm and so i'm just trying i'm just
looking at you man to man friend to
friend and going i'm going to serve you
well
and so
you know i've had and our leadership
team have had conversations with people
inside of our organization
over the years
almost on a weekly basis someone we sit
down with and say listen i love you too
much
to just not tell you this
you got it you got to know
this is this right here is killing you
this is hurting you
and and so because here's the thing
you're serving him then what you got to
do is you got to go okay if he has a
lack of judgment over there
how long before that lack of judgment
regardless of how much he cares
enters into our organization
if his critical thinking skills have got
him this far in debt i mean he's going
to start making stupid butt decisions at
work too
and so we got to get him off the stupid
butt train and get him on the train
where he can learn and that's just
loving the guy well that's serving him
when i serve my children and they're
growing up it means i teach them how to
behave and function in society
it doesn't mean the inmates run the
asylum
uh because i love my kids enough to
serve i'm going to serve you i'm going
to make sure you know how to drive a
dadgum car before i give you the keys
i'm going to make sure you know how to
behave and say yes ma'am and yes sir and
thank you
and gratitude and you know all you know
that kind of a thing and so you're
serving someone by loving them well yeah
and by having hard difficult
conversations with them yeah you got to
sit down in this situation you say hey
you're looking for a second job that
means more work hours a week more time
away from your family and this is all
because you're not showing discipline
over here and when you show them your
teaching you're guiding you're
instructing shoot them straight i'll
i'll pay for you to go i'll pay for your
ramsey plus membership and you go you
know you you uh that's what you tell him
and you go i'll walk with you and i'll
coach you and because i think you've got
huge rock star potential as a leader
because of your passion for this place
and i really want to pour into you and
lift you up yeah and you can set a model
in place then on how you lead people for
the rest of your life there really cool
question charlie you got a good heart
man
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones a triple eight
eight two five
five
matt is with us in springfield missouri
hey matt welcome to the show how can we
help
hey dave thanks for taking my call sure
um so
long story short here my wife and i
bought a house in 2012
at about 160 000
and we spent the last eight years
paying off our house and we just did
that last year in july
and now my wife's wanting to move again
and because her office got closed down
during the covid
pandemic and she ended up
working remotely from home now
permanently and so
i'm having trouble coming to terms with
wanting to possibly take on another
mortgage and so i'm kind of
needing some advice on how i should
handle this
uh um okay so your current home is worth
what
we bought the home for 160 in 2012 and
right now it's probably worth about 280.
okay
and what's wrong with the house you have
now
nothing wrong with it she just one she
doesn't like the layout and two there's
no office space for her we're in a
home like she works from the kitchen
table and we have you know kids and
everything and uh
it gets noisy and she can't you know do
client calls and stuff like that because
it's too distracting
okay so why couldn't you buy a 280 000
home with a different layout and that
had an office
well we've been looking and uh we
haven't found anything in our area
uh of that price and uh with the layout
because you haven't looked in that
neighborhood you've been looking in
those expensive neighborhoods
you could say that yeah
no i'm sure of it i mean you know yeah
that's the logo you're looking in the
wrong neighborhood if you want to stay
out of debt right
well i i do want to stay out of that i
don't know why are you looking in the
neighborhood that has debt
uh that's a good question but uh the
the area has just shot up so high that
you know well then yours should have
been shot up
i mean a 280 000 home in springfield
missouri's no slouch dude
that's a that's a decent house and you
could have a differently configured home
that included a different layout and
config included that for that same money
and just swap houses
yeah but what we're doing is we're using
all this other bs as an excuse to move
up in house that's really what it comes
down to
yeah
yeah i guess you could say that
yeah
i mean i want a different kitchen that's
got like 70 000 more worth of crap in it
and i'm using this i'm working at the
kitchen table whining as my excuse to go
into that again so where in the process
did you all lose or did she lose the
vision of being debt-free on your home
is uh worth it
uh well i think it's just been over the
course of since she's had to work from
home
the constant interruptions with
uh
kids being in the area and her trying to
handle phone calls and get work done and
go renter in office
yeah we've we've talked about that but
we do pay for a private school as well
for our children
and
we haven't been able to justify the cost
of getting a rental office or her her
business did have her set up to go to a
rental office's office spaces and then
they got rid of that option
what kind of work is she doing
she's a hr consultant
so she's on the phone
80 of the day
yeah she's handling she does a
compensation mail analysis uh executive
analysis who's watching the kids when
they're not in school like how many kids
are running around we have two kids and
it will usually be me uh
watching them
but i i do shift work so i'll one week
i'm working nights the next week i'm
working evenings so i have a crazy work
schedule i work weekends yeah well let
me just tell you something by yourself
let me say something dave's absolutely
right youtube this is a relationship
thing you guys got to sit down and and
re re-establish the why why did we do
all this for eight years what was the
whole purpose of this
and you know this is a pretty easy solve
number one you're living in a hundred
sixty thousand dollar area so today's
point the two days
yeah i know well i'm saying that's what
they were yeah that's what they bought
at yeah and then so there's a couple
neighborhoods up so i think it's unsafe
it's not like schools are awful so i
think this big bad world you're in the
other thing is is that you know she can
work at the coffee shop or something
just you know and make phone calls and
step out or do whatever i just i just
think this idea that we got to move
somewhere
uh for her to have a place to work
besides the kitchen table i i just think
that's a relationship thing where you
guys have to re-establish the why behind
this and then say okay we're willing to
do this but we're not willing to go
beyond the 280. and if we can't get
happy with something for 280 cash
then
you have to come up with another solve
until you save up enough to be able to
do something you want i mean what's your
household income
175 a year
go rent an office yeah
okay today
okay and then if you want to trade
houses trade houses but that off listen
the tails wagon the dog here you're
making a bad financial decision for a
temporary situation
right yeah we're working at the kitchen
table is not the way it's going to be
for the next decade
right she's not going to be at the
kitchen table for a decade and you don't
you don't go
buy a house
uh because of something that happened
with covid
these are you know i do not know when
she'll be back at work or when they'll
be funding the office but you make
plenty of money and so for
you know what four or five hundred bucks
you can go rent a single office in one
of these office suites and just you know
she can plan herself down there and then
she's got a work environment that's
reasonable
and then if you want to trade houses for
a better layout that's fine you could
guys can do whatever you want you got a
lot of excuses for a guy that called in
wanting help not to do this and i'm just
telling you don't do it
there's no chance
no chance
that i'm going into that in this
situation
none
this is all a bunch of i want it and i'm
a little bit uncomfortable and i'm sorry
you're uncomfortable i'm sorry she's
uncomfortable
whoopi
don't put yourself back into a mortgage
over that
you finally got yourself free man
remember what it was like having that
thing hanging around your neck don't go
back into the noose don't stick your
head back in there man don't put your
foot in a bear trap again
them things hurt man don't do it
don't do it please please don't do it
and and you know but you
you know is there a valid part of this
that she's trying to do business in an
unprofessional situation yeah go around
an office and do it tomorrow that's what
i would do in your situation i'm not
going into debt
for an office in your home
over covet
no you know what the new thing is now is
literally these uh closets that are
offices it's like a new thing uh you
look it up online i'm not kidding where
people are turning closets into
miniature offices
we could at least do that no i'm not
going in the closet
she makes 175 000. i agree i'm trying to
give him a non-rent option i just you
know there's another place besides the
kitchen table yeah but i agree with you
you can go get an office yeah
yeah
but here here's the thing it's a vis
where there is no vision that people
perish
if you work really hard to get out of
debt because you believe
that your life is so much better being
debt-free you have so much higher
probability of building wealth by being
debt-free
you would never go back
but you quit believing that somewhere
along the line
and we're willing to trade that for
the inconvenience of the current
situation and i'm not willing to trade
it no the the difference is that
when we went broke and lost everything i
said never again and i meant it
never again
are these bozos going to have their
thumb on my neck
never again is american express gonna
call my house unless it's a wrong number
never again
there's not a chance i am not going back
there's not anything you people can do
to scare me enough there's nothing you
can do to make me mad enough there's not
anything you can do to make me greedy
enough
passionate enough to go into debt
the borrower is slave to the lender and
i am free
and i am never
going back it's easy for me to say
and and i can't imagine you and stacey
having that conversation to be any
different no yeah it's
look
every time that you allow your emotions
to drive you
then then you lose sight of decisions
that you have made
many you know what i mean and your
critical thinking skills critical
thinking is gone and i feel this i feel
this i feel this and in this situation
you made a great recommendation they can
upgrade and still be
mortgage-free yeah
it's easy
it's not a bad it's not like
not enough enough enough that puts this
hour of the ramsey show in the books
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsay call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host ken
coleman ramsey personality is my co-host
today thank you for joining us open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five anders
in washington d.c hey andrew how are you
good dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
so uh we've been working the plan for
three years um we paid off just under a
hundred thousand dollars in debt and
then the next two years spent
saving up and obviously doing the
emergency fund and we did the 3b we
saved almost 200 000 we put down money
on the house then we have our emergency
fund in place great so we're looking to
kind of do the four five and six perfect
um
now
the 15
got that that's great we start investing
in retirement and now the question i
have is
the 529 should i do that or a
separate broker's account that's not a
traditional 529 specifically with our
income and then we don't know if our
kids are or are not going to go to
college
okay
well
uh
what is your household income
so right now it's a little over 200 but
kind of projected to go up okay
well to start with no one knows that
they're killing kids are going to go to
college but we're for sure
know that if they don't have the money
it's going to be harder
so a 529 grows tax-free
i love keeping the government's hands
off the growth
it can be transferred to a sibling it
can be transferred to a parent
another family member
it can be transferred if they don't use
it if they got scholarships they can you
can pull from a 529 the equivalent
amount of the scholarship with no taxes
tax-free growth and so yeah i'm doing a
529
i'm not going to over fund it if you
have concerns i'm not going to put 200
000 in there
but but i'm definitely going to put 40
or 50 60 grand in there depending on the
age of the kid
and maybe even more but uh uh
and let it grow
you know a brokerage account
infers that you're buying and selling
stocks
and you don't need to be doing that
especially for your kids college
so i don't want that much risk i just
use good growth stock mutual funds in a
tax-free growth in a 529
and that and you choose the mutual funds
and you choose to move them around
that's the type of 529 you want we're
very specific about that in our in
financial peace university and in the
total money makeover but yeah just
you know you don't have to overdo it but
don't under do it either and overthink
it
about whether your kid's going to
college or not
interesting so when we start the show 30
years ago the assumption was everybody
wanted their kid to go to college
and now they don't
yeah and increasingly becoming the case
but also point out here that these 529
plans that money can be used for
non-traditional college education as
well so trade schools that's anything
from tech schools i mean you can use
that and and so you're seeing more and
more opportunities for people to get
qualified to do the work they want to do
so it's not like you're you're you're
being unwise buying it for their private
school when they're 1 k through 12. you
can that's exactly right so it's still
the best option yeah keeping the
government's hands off the taxes and not
screwing around with the money with
single stock trades acting like you and
your buddy eating a biscuit at cracker
barrel have a clue what's going on don't
do it don't do it man and just get in
there and some mutual funds those guys
are on the mutual fund they're not
coming coming to work in a car longer
than your house they know what's going
on so it's it's not perfect but that's
where all of my kids college money was
so i'm not being hypocritical
uh and so yeah i'm doing a 529 you can
use private school while they're uh
k-12 you can do any kind of
post-secondary education there's all
kinds of stuff you can use it for
legally and it keeps the government's
hands off of it
and so you know if you put twenty
thousand dollars in there and it grows
to eighty or a hundred
that's eighty thousand dollars with no
taxes on it
i like that
i like that a lot better than screwing
around with it in a brokerage account
that's right and a lot of options tons
of options
uh
gustavo is with us in tucson i
mispronounced that how do you pronounce
your name
sir i did say it you nailed it well it
didn't mess it up
hillbilly spanish is just a hard thing
dude i'm just saying
so what's up man
uh well i kind of had like a weird
question that
i'm on baby step i'm finishing up baby
step three next month just to give you a
heads up of where i'm at
and
i want to get a toy i had one when i was
in debt but
i want to make sure it's kind of weird
because my vehicles aren't worth too
much
and the toy that i'm looking into which
is the rzr razor
run they run about 15 000 news and
that's more than my vehicles
combined but i'm we're kind of happy
with our vehicle so that's where my
question is kind of
is it weird that my toy would be more
expensive than my vehicles even though
we would be in a position to of quiet
catch yes
all right
i mean it's which it's weird you know
it's weird that's why you're asking
right you already knew it's weird but
it's cool
they're neat they're neat vehicles man
you're talking about the the um
is it the can-am make that who makes
that
the razer does uh polaris polaris makes
it yeah that's right
yeah
yeah i've got some friends down at cabo
that have have them and they all ride up
the beach at cabo those those things are
very cool they they look they look neat
too man and they will haul butt they
they're fun yes so uh
yeah and you're you're in tucson so
you're doing like desert desert action
with the thing huh
right yeah i mean i could make it all
the way to phoenix i'm sure yeah i bet
you could yeah that's they're they're
very cool it's a cool vehicle i i kind
of want i kind of want one myself but um
anyway the
yeah uh your cars are uh your your daily
driver transportation your family
depends on those your income is
dependent upon those
um and so yeah the uh you know a
snowmobile a sea doo a boat
uh a razor should not be
worth more than your cars
uh it's just kind of a common sense
thing it's not really a financial thing
uh so right all it says is that you're
probably not quite there yet that would
be my opinion and of course you made the
mistake of asking so
i'll give you my opinion but the um
yeah that's i i
i mean you've got you got a toy in your
house i do but it was a gift to you on
that it was and as you know i'm cash
flowing the renovation of it yeah he has
a classic car yeah got a 72 convertible
karma ghia uh found an old guy uh in the
hood that loves working on him and so
he's gonna help me put the carpet kit in
and just do a little bit at a time
because we have kids in school and and
other things and and so you just have to
go at the speed of cash like you said
when we built this place and so i got
the exterior done still a little bit
more to do and it still looks pretty
sweet it looks sweet but yeah you have
to kind of what's the ratio on that i
mean understand what he's saying he's
like well i got baby step three now he
needs to get the baby step four actually
put that in the budget then he needs to
begin to save for something like that
yeah and you you know i i
and i don't know that i have a rule and
i'm just kind of sitting here thinking
on the fly but right really you're if
you're if your boat is
eighty thousand dollars and your cars
are ten thousand dollars that just seems
it doesn't seem right you know and so if
your razor's fifteen thousand and your
cars are five thousand that seems
backwards yeah you know and it but those
razors are very cool they're very yeah i
think he may have talked you into buying
wise i don't need one right i don't know
why but i'm probably just because it has
a motor and goes because it's fast it
goes wooden wooden there you go man
so probably got a loud muffler i can
make a redneck muffler on it oh sure
redneck anything up you know that there
you go
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
health care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business
check us out at
chministries.org
we absolutely believe in it
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
825-5225
if you're tired of feeling stuck with
your money like you'll never get out of
debt or save enough it doesn't have to
be that way you can get a ramsey plus
membership that includes
the ever dollar budgeting app the
world's best budgeting app it includes
financial peace university where you can
go through the class learn step by step
how to get out of debt like millions
literally of people have done
when you budget you get intentional with
your money you get a clear path you
start working it you're going to make
progress you're going to make it fast
you can start budgeting you can start
making these steps free
starting today with a free trial of
ramsey plus text trial to 33
789
text trial
three three
seven
eight
nine ld is with us in indianapolis
hi l.d welcome to the ramsey show
i did listen to you for a long time
my wife last night or
you really have a first baby
hey
when's he coming
anytime you know all right good for you
yeah yeah pretty excited
uh we got
some pretty total goals for the future
and so we'd like to
we're trying to grow our income as much
as possible
trying to decide if now would be a good
time for her to
maybe advance her career and become a
dental hygienist
she's an assistant right now but it put
about 10 to 12 an hour on her pay
uh caveat to that would be
we one of our goals is for her to be
able to stay at home and be a bigger
part of our business
within the next 10 12 years or so and so
just trying to decide if it's
if it's justifiable i guess
interesting so what would she do in the
business if she stayed home with the
baby and babies potentially and worked
in the business what would she be doing
uh with
a farm
full-time i'm a farmer and
so you know she
she's uh she's also a pretty good
bookkeeper and things like that and so
okay uh my mom take my mom takes care of
a lot of that right now but you know in
the future
okay so so she saves you money by doing
the bookkeeping that you're paying
someone else to do or she's replacing
mom
she would probably be
you know doing a lot of what my mom does
okay so you have to weigh all right she
wants to be home sounds like that's what
both of you want
versus she now continues to work and
there's the cost of the schooling the
cost of getting qualified to become that
dental hygienist and you're looking at
ten to twelve dollars an hour so you
start weighing opportunity cost
with the emotional costs and i think
that if it's stacey and i we're gonna
sit down together in the old-fashioned
grandpa and and grandma conversation the
pros and cons of both of those so which
way does her heart lead the most which
if if things were just
has she wanted them forget about the
money equation and making more money and
all the benefits that come with that
what does her heart want to do
oh she definitely wants to be able to
stay at home at some point all right so
why are you back and forth on this where
were you at the start of this phone call
would like i said
we just
we've got some
some things we'd like to accomplish and
her her income
helps helps with
getting there what does she make
she makes about 30 right now okay so
that this would put her at about 40.
uh
hygienists are in our area are in that
50s yeah 50s 50s okay i mean okay and so
um
what does hygienic school cost
uh
well we live in the middle of nowhere
and so it's about 30 000 but it'd be a
pretty good
a lot of travel time involved with that
too it was a new baby two
right takes two and a half years yeah
so we have time and money here that
we're popular
right right yeah
this is more than just working for uh
working uh
with the baby at home this is uh two and
a half years of training
in it and by by the way during that time
she's not working right
it'd be pretty tough it'd be pretty
tough on her yeah yeah yeah so
it's costing you 30 a year in income
and it's costing you 30 000 over two and
a half years and she's traveling and
gone
so that after two and a half years she
works for six years making twenty
thousand dollars more i mean you're
gonna she's gonna
make money on this transaction but it
doesn't sound like it's worth it
yeah yeah that's been her back and forth
yeah it sounds like by the time i mean
if she was gonna do it for the rest of
her life and make an extra 20 000 a year
and loved it and it was the long-term
goal
that might then the equation starts to
work
mathematically yeah but right now you're
not going to get enough of her increased
income before she's
willing or before she's able to come
home i think you start figuring out what
she could do from home
to create an income
while she's helping you with the farm
stuff in there with the babies i think
maybe we look at shifting that i bet you
she could come up with a side gig like a
christy wright business boutique idea
um
i mean if it's just selling stuff on
ebay i don't care what it is yeah and
then it may be streamlining operations
on the farm remember we're saving money
that's more money in our pockets
certainly to a farmer you know the thing
that point out here uh is ld is that her
heart
is not in it if i heard on there that
her heart she wanted to be a dental
hygienist what she's always wanted to do
she loves it loves it loves it but she
also wants to be a mom for a season then
i think this is an investment and a
sacrifice that you figure out how to do
but i'm going to tell you with that kind
of schedule the schooling you're losing
your income as it is that's going to
create all types of sacrifices and a
squeeze and and when you don't have the
drive the juice for something
i'm gonna tell you it makes it really
really difficult and it can put you
behind emotionally not just financially
daniel's in columbia south carolina hi
daniel welcome to the ramsay show
hello dave thanks for thanking my call
sure what's up
all right so um i'm in baby step six um
i'm 27 and my wife is 25. um basically
my mom reached out to me um asking for
help
um she had a lease
of the fleece
and she want to pay it off basically
it ended up
the lease ends up this month um
and she asked me to to borrow
from me
to
to 2k
and basically um she asked me not to
tell my wife and obviously you know we
are we have jones account and also um
what's your question
yeah what what's your advice in my
situation i don't do anything that i
can't tell my wife
anything ever
if i'm in a meeting and they say all the
discussion in this meeting has to stay
in this room you can't tell your wife i
get up and leave the meeting
there are no things on this planet that
i can't tell sharon
that is against the law at ramsey world
it will get your throat cut by your wife
while you're asleep dude
you can't be hiding crap from your wife
hello is that right yeah
yes i'm trying i mean your mom is out of
control
where's your dad are they divorced yeah
no they're they are together they have
separate accounts and actually my dad
let him lent her
10k
to he lent his own wife money
yes that's strange
okay so uh
mom i can't do anything that
i love you but i can't do anything that
i can't tell my wife
and don't ever suggest that again
because it's not gonna it's not a
profitable conversation for us to have
okay mom can't do that and if you need
uh two thousand dollars you need to talk
to your husband my dad and you guys need
to work on your finances and get them
get them combined and get them
straightened out
but i i think your mom i think your mom
is trying to hide all of this from
everybody
and still trying to find a way to snake
her way through this and it's time that
the cards are played a face up on the
table
mom is getting ready to be exposed
and needs to be yeah needs to be so she
needs to talk to your dad and she and
your dad have got a lot of work to do
but you don't need to get involved in
this son you just lovingly say no i
don't hide things from my wife and i
really think you need to talk to dad
about this he's got the money and you
guys have the money and you all need to
fix this
so sorry can't do it love you mom love
you mom no chance
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today on the phones in
minneapolis
is going to be kristin who says on my
screen kristen you're debt free
congratulations
thank you hi guys hey how much have you
paid off
61 091.37
love it how long did this take
48 months good for you and your range of
income during that time
okay i went back and checked and it was
32 000
to 51 000 and now back down to about 40.
wow
so what do you do for a living
i'm an accountant and recently a ramsey
master financial coach ah okay so
starting to get some extra income that
way yeah very good good for you
so what kind of debt was the 61 000
so a lot of it was medical just kind of
stuff that
surgeries
children being born and then just like
once we would accumulate it it would
just hang around and
payments payments payments there was
some personal loans
and a big family loan that we had to do
repairs on our home
okay wow good for you so how much was
the big family loan
that was was like 22 000 that was the
big one of the whole bunch then that was
the big guy hiding in the closet yeah
gotcha okay
so what happened four years ago that put
you on this journey
so my marriage was coming to an end and
that's when we separated our money
and i had always wanted to be debt-free
and become an edm
so that was like pedal to the metal
okay so fresh start after the divorce
yep
and um you already knew about our stuff
but you were just now able to do it
because of the
the disagreement in the household before
yeah it was like uh you know
putting on a lot of throttle and the car
is in neutral now now i actually got
some
traction okay good for you
all right so you're going to be an
everyday millionaire that's your future
i love that
yeah and what do you tell people when
you're coaching them now that the key to
getting out of debt is because you paid
off 61 000 in four years making 32.
yeah for me
there was three
three things and i would say the reason
which is my voice
the plan obviously and then just the
determination
so we just saw a picture of the
four boys right
yep on youtube there good looking family
yeah thanks that's fun you got a lot of
why there
yes
wow for sure so i i want to ask you when
you decide it's you're coming out of
this divorce so that's a painful thing
and you decide all right i'm going to
restart reboot do it the way that i
always wanted to do it you've got those
boys as your why every day looking at
him
uh
what what
fired you up the most in this process
was it the first one the first debt that
you paid off on the debt snowball was it
just the boys um what was the real
driver for you once you got into the
process where you began to experience
some momentum
i think i had a lot of little loans so
getting started and getting those paid
off there was a lot of immediate
you know payoff for those
and i just knew
what i wanted to give them i didn't i
didn't want a house full of stress
and i wanted to give them a good future
not like just giving them money but
showing them
what to do and they
they hold me accountable i got a debit
card mail to me and i open it up and
they're like mom
is that a credit card
they're always watching me that's great
that's so fun
very cool so they know the rules then
they know what you have to do oh yeah
yeah
very very fun
cool
so um
how long had you been familiar with our
stuff before your marriage ended
uh quite a while
um i think my folks
introduced me to your radio show and
back in like 2010
and then
i coordinated and fpu starting in 2011
and then i did another one before my
last son was born so i've done a couple
of those
and i was just kind of hooked because
i'm a natural saver
and so
once kind of the shackles were off
and we found a better church that i
wanted to be at and i started tithing
again
and i think dave you had said like a
month ago when you talked about god
throwing open the window of heaven
he sure did in my case because it's like
once you know we were pushing the bike
down the hill
everything just kept piling on i swear i
have food show up in my freezer that
wasn't there
i had a expedition that i think two of
the pictures are like a time lapse that
i got when my son was seven months old
the oldest one and he's 12 now and i've
still got it it's just about 300 000
miles on it
but stuff just
kept being a benefit there was just kind
of blessings from everywhere wow can i
ask you what did you do to take go from
32 to 51k what happened
um i my regular job was not 40 hours so
i had a base of that and then i did a
lot of side accounting work
and then just try to get and i got a
couple more clients and stuff like that
and then um i worked for my mom who's a
cpa and i did tax work at night
just kind of everywhere i could pull
from yeah that's great very good you're
a hustler yeah you're getting her done
girl proud of you very very well done
good job who are your biggest
cheerleaders other than your boys
um i would say my parents because
they've been down that road and they've
been debt free for a while i have a lot
of friends i don't have a lot of
naysayer friends i got a lot of friends
who are debt free or are on their way
and then yeah these these kids i can't
say enough about them because they never
complained they knew what the plan was
they volunteered i don't need a treat we
can save it
so i'm just really proud of what they
have learned and how they keep me
accountable very cool very cool
powerful kristen what are the boys names
so aiden is 12.
gavin is nine
mason is seven
and morgan is four so we're going to try
to coordinate it they're coming in here
they're going to do the screen
all right they've earned it no question
about it very cool what a great family
project we're proud of you great job
we've got a copy of the legacy journey
which is the next uh chapter in your
story as you said you're gonna be an edm
and everyday millionaire you are on your
way kiddo and uh and of course another
copy of the total money makeover which
you'll be able to give to someone and
pay it forward and get somebody else's
uh journey started with that
best-selling book so good stuff all
right kristen and the gang
61 000
paid off in 48 months making 32 000
extra side hustles up to 51 part of that
time count it down let's hear a debt
free scream
all right ready boy
three
two
one
[Applause]
i love that sound yes that is the sound
of a family tree being changed right
there you heard it yes those boys lived
that with her yeah what a legacy single
mom
uh leading
modeling the way i just you know i'm
always blown away by the stories of
everybody we get to hear their debt-free
journey but certainly
uh you know anthony o'neil and i got to
host a show last week or a single mom
making 32 000
same thing same thing and i i have a
special place in my heart for those
ladies yeah step up and do that we all
do it's hard enough to parent uh
certainly by yourself and then and then
go through that debt-free journey i want
to point out something dave that i
thought was so heartwarming you asked
her who were her biggest cheerleaders
and she said beyond her parents
were friends she said they weren't
naysayers
they had been on the journey themselves
and i just want to point that out
that when you decide to live like no one
else you better hang out with people
that are that are on board and will
support you you become who you hang
around with
birds of a feather
you read what they read that's true you
talk like they talk
you um
you know you attend church like they
attend church you treat your spouse like
they treat their spouse i mean this is
this is you become who you hang around
with so choose carefully my friends
choose carefully
this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
carol is with us in sacramento hi carol
welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve how can ken and i help
okay i have a question i'm actually a
ramsay coach and also an everyday
millionaire
we have three homes that are paid for
and we are also a co-owner with one of
our children due to due to a divorce
our question is this
if we sell one of the rental homes we
could net about 560 000
which is almost enough to pay off the
kids homes and surprise them
we don't quite have enough or about 60k
short of paying off both of the homes
should we do that or should we
keep the house or should we sell it and
put the money in mutual funds
i'm confused you said kids
homes two homes we have
yes two homes
okay and two adult children okay and
we're co-owners on one of the homes
okay but you would pay it off and
surrender that
ownership yes okay because you're only a
co-owner because you had to bail them
out in the divorce
yes and then my our other kid has his
own home
and um okay so you sell the rental and
it brings 560 000 but you need 620 000
to do this
exactly and you don't have the other
cash
we kind of do i just don't know if it's
smart to pull that out of because we
would we have other funds it's not our
retirement funds i just don't know if
it's smart to do right now
um we're getting eaten alive in capital
gains we're paying about 200 000 in
capital gains so what is your net worth
probably about three million
okay
uh
i would do it but i would only do it if
you pull out enough out of your other
investments in order to actually do it
if you don't actually pay off the
mortgages it kind of defeats the purpose
doesn't it
yeah kind of because from what i
understand um in california you can only
get so much money per year so we may not
be able to do the whole thing all in one
uh
you i don't know california law but in
this in the
the federal taxes there you have a gift
tax limitation that this is well in
excess of but you can use some of your
federal estate tax exemption called a
unified estate tax credit
and you just have to do a file you have
to unified as state tax credit
and you're using some of your federal
exemption
up
so when you die you would have used some
of it up already
um but you're nowhere near the limits
anyway it's like 20 million so you're
fine that's what you would do to get rid
of the federal gift tax
i do not know california tax law at all
so you'd want to you'd want to consult a
tax professional to figure that out i
suspect that that unified estate tax
credit would also apply in california
i i bet you it's aligned with the
federal guidelines this is my guess
i'll be shocked if it's not
um but california does some weird butt
stuff to tax our people so i don't know
um but anyway yeah so uh
your net worth now becomes two and a
half and they have paid for houses the
only other question i've got is would
they commit to never borrowing money
again for anything
yes yeah i wouldn't make it a big deal
but i probably would have like a little
one-page letter in both of them and
their spouses sign it
if we pay off your home you never borrow
money again and so our family tree is
completely changed
never borrow money again for anything
for any reason
yeah
ever and by the way you shouldn't have
to if you don't have a house payment
you'll be able to save up and buy
anything you want to buy
yeah yeah that's and just
you know we we bring in a nice income
off of the rent we don't have to have it
so that's kind of my dilemma too i'm
just like
should we how old are you
sorry how old are you guys
we're in our 60s yeah i would do it yeah
really yeah
okay and pull the other 60k out of
yes i would not do it unless you're
going to pay them off i mean there's no
point in paying it down that doesn't do
anything you still have a stringent
mortgage so but get rid of the the debt
and have them both sign a little
one-page letter
um just type it up and just talk about
legacy and how you want to change your
family tree and
everybody participates i think that's a
fair trade and then after that you just
don't bring it up and you can't go
managing their finances anymore this is
their life you don't get to interfere
this is a gift
uh but it's pr the gift is predicated on
the fact that we're changing our family
tree and that is a fair
level of control in return for the gift
yeah let me ask you on that are you
saying in the letter that they are
committing
they're just asking the kids to commit
to that they're not going to be checking
up on them that's what you're getting at
correct there's no strings attached but
it kind of is well it's a it's a promise
yeah i like that it's just a promise i
promise in return for having my mortgage
paid off to never borrow money yeah i
think that's fair
that's a family oath so to speak but
it's not a it's not a legal commitment
and no you're not going to check up on
them once a year and look at their
balance sheets and no you're not doing
any of that it's just like you know if
they go and buy a house and put it on a
mortgage in the future you would just
look at them and say you broke your
promise
you know that's it that's all it is and
then you just go well that's sad you
broke your promise
because you shouldn't have had to yeah
if you're because the kids are going to
be millionaires pretty quick oh yeah no
question about it they'll be there very
very quickly depending if they're if
they are you know learning from their
parents model
uh to not borrow and to be generous and
to be investors they'll get there very
very quickly
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five matthews in
phoenix hi matthew how are you
doing well dave yourself better than i
deserve how can we help
i have a question about refinancing we
owe about 131
on the house with about seven years left
of payments after refinancing about
eight years ago
and my wife is going to be losing uh
going on to uh full disability probably
within the next six months to a year and
unable to work which will be cutting our
income into half
uh to have money for medical
expenses would it be smart to refinance
to lower the
um house payment to cover medical
expenses in the future
what do you make
uh currently uh 45 for my work and then
with the veteran uh disability i collect
another 24 000 so about 65
a year nine yeah and then your house
payment's about 15.50
okay um what does she make
uh currently about
60 to 70 so after
uh she's what is the nature what is the
nature of her disability
uh it's a terminal um illness that's
slowly debilitating her where she has uh
chronic fatigue and unable to stay awake
or uh work
oh my
how old is she uh
mid-40s and i'm in my mid-30s wow
i'm sorry man
uh that's a battle we've been going
through but still staying strong and
trying to follow your way as best as
possible to
prepare for the upcoming future of
her health issues
seven years is so fast you're going to
be done i hate to have you walk away
from that but i would not trade uh
quality of life if we've got a terminal
diagnosis for anything
so
yeah i probably would can i probably
would consider just because
i don't only want you to have the wiggle
room to make sure you got medical bills
and stuff covered i think you can cover
the house payment i think you could cut
it out and make it but it might mean
that you don't get to do some things
with her that you need to do
while she can
exactly so it was the odd of being
debt-free because we only owe 131 on the
house and you're almost there in seven
years oh i hate to have you lose that
but
yeah if you put that on a 15 it will
relax that payment considerable
and uh you can circle back later
and maybe still make it in seven years
or or eight years or something you never
know
exactly where this journey is going to
take you but
um
yeah i mean you you you need to
concentrate on her
okay just wanted to hear from you
because i know always snowball forward
and we've been doing really good the
last seven years after taking your
course
i would love to see you finish it up but
not if it means that
you lose some experiences with the time
you have with her
that's not a that's not a good trade
i i wouldn't
but either way is okay but i just
wow heartbreaking i'm sorry
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show did you know over 18
million people listen to the ramsay show
every week and a lot of those people
listen on one of our 600 plus radio
stations across the country
to find a station near you head to
thermsyshow.com
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host ken
coleman ramsey personality is my co-host
today he is the host of the ken coleman
show which is where you learn all about
your career all about jobs all about how
to get them how about how to find the
work you love and so if you have
questions about career and work he's
here to help and we're here to help you
in general so jump in at triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight eight two five
five two two five
canal is with us canal is in columbus
ohio hi canal what's up
hi how you doing better than i deserve
how can we
help i had a quick question about
self banking with whole term life
insurance
and whether it's worth it if you accrue
a cash balance and borrow
against that and pay interest to
yourself
or if you should stay away from that and
keep using a bank
yeah um it's an absolute scam
it's a whole life policy it's not a turn
it's not a term policy
it's a whole life life insurance policy
basically whole life life insurance is
where you pay 20 times more
for the same amount of insurance
and so the extra 95
out of the hundred dollars goes into a
savings account
and um that you earn very little on
after you finally start to build it up
and then one of the ways they're
pitching it now is the self-banking
concept where you use your own money
which by the way when you have a
checking account you are using your own
money i don't know why they think that's
magical
okay perfect i guess i won't use that no
i i wouldn't use it i would stay
completely away from the company that is
offering it and any other offerings that
they have
because it is a really really bad
product
and it is a scummy way to sell whole
life life insurance which is a scummy
product to start with
but no one sells that stuff anymore
except people no one believes in it or
talks about it positively except people
that are in that business
and this whole thing of you can borrow
your own money why would i want to
borrow my it doesn't even make any sense
dave but this is the power of marketing
i mean the message here is really look
into stuff i love that people can call
and get advice on this but really dig
into stuff and and and does it make
sense and if it doesn't make sense why
doesn't it make sense but they've put
some wonderful marketing copy on this
yeah so
from yourself give you another one it
just keeps it
yeah isn't that great and you pay and
you pay them interest
right to borrow money from to borrow
your money that you saved up in your
savings you're moving money from your
checking account to put it over there to
them to not even get a good return on it
to get it back it's just it's
mind-numbing it's like moving a pile of
rocks from one side of the yard to the
other back and forth back and forth back
and forth
and so here's the other one uh whole
life life insurance you can uh you can
use it cash value insurance grows
tax-free
well no it doesn't
that's a lie but here's how they propose
that you do this
you overpay for your insurance by 20
times for all of your life your whole
life that's where it comes from they
take your money your whole life
and finally you have some money in there
let's just say you've got 50 000 in
there
now if
the
50 000 is in excess of
what you paid in
and you take it out that is taxable
because there's a gain right yes but
not if you borrow it
and so you put money into this
investment now you can borrow
your money
that you put in there
back out
and pay them interest
but it's tax-free yeah well no kidding
doofus when you go to the bank and
borrow 50 000 they don't charge you
taxes on it it's a debt yeah
of course it's not taxable debt is not
taxable but it's not a tax-free growth
on an investment like a roth ira or roth
401k it's not even on the same planet
yeah
it's the same kind of stuff that he's
dealing with there and it's this whole
idea of but but boy i mean
you talk about i mean they're almost as
scummy as the timeshare people yeah
they're almost that scummy yeah they're
almost as scummy as the payday lenders
they're right up there that's straight
up manipulation what you just laid out
for us as clear as you could lay it out
that's manipulating people
lying yeah we could call it dave ramsey
is giving bad advice because with whole
life you could get tax-free growth
no you can't yeah no
you can borrow your own
money
and pay them interest right and borrowed
money is always tax-free because it's
borrowed right it's not an actual
investment
so yeah that's how that works
but but i'm the crook and i'm the one
that doesn't know what he's talking
about according to that industry
now if you want some people pissed off
at you that's a good group of people to
have pissed off at you the time share
people are pissed off at me yeah the uh
car fleecing people are pissed off at me
the payday lenders hate my guts
and the whole life people oh my god you
would think i would have you taken on
the rent to own furniture people yet you
know they just don't do much anymore
right okay i'm just trying to think of
anybody else while we're we should just
go ahead and get a full list of the
scumbags people you don't get christmas
cards from yeah
yeah
well i mean rent to own is actually you
know i have they are taking on a couple
of our books and a couple of our courses
over there yeah but i don't really hear
from them much yeah it's not a popular
moment yeah the nothing down same as
cash
furniture people they're not happy with
me no best buy screwing people with that
stuff for decades yeah this ain't the
best buy people yeah you know it's not
hard to figure out yeah the product
protection plan people they don't like
either yeah yeah
all the extras why is it that everybody
makes you the bad guy because you're
trying to save people money well i'm
just trying to save people that's the
point yeah you're hurting the big
corporate scams and so that's why they
come at you yeah like everybody didn't
already know payday lenders were a screw
job
like like all of america knows time
everybody knows a time share is like the
worst thing on the planet yeah and like
they're shocked that dave ramsey said it
out loud the time shares are scummy yeah
oh my god of course we said it out loud
they were scummy long before i back when
i had a hair they were scum yeah well
when you offer all these free things
just for a meeting which by the way i
did it one time you didn't i did you
went in the tiger cage yeah because the
package was so nice and stable you see
the tiger for an hour
and you get a free pass to the zoo for a
year
tiger hasn't eaten in four days but come
in the cage and pet the tiger for an
hour oh here's the deal i didn't pay
attention to my wife this is a great
story
she's like you're gonna have to sit
there and listen i'm like trust me i
won't i'm the guy that goes there's no
chance well i went in just mr stonewall
i'm not gonna do it like you're the only
one's ever done that i know and then sat
there and just got worn out i tried to
be rude i tried to get kicked out
i'll give the guy credit he made me sit
there for 90 minutes but i'll tell you
what i got all the stuff too so that was
it it was the last time i did it it was
not worth it it's our first year of
marriage buy your own hotel room yes
buy your own hotel room it ain't worth
it no don't pet the tiger in the tiger
cage yeah it's good he will eat your
butt yeah you'll come out of there with
a 26 000 time share that's worth a
dollar yeah you can't sell it for a
dollar on ebay you can't get out of it
no you is stuck baby you've been petting
a tiger don't go in the tiger cage
no wonder he hadn't eaten in three days
there's nothing as greedy as a time
share salesman oh my god
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk they use
the same network as the larger providers
for much less for just 30 a month get
unlimited talk text and six gigs of data
with no contract the average family
saves over 70 a month by switching to
pure top just go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month pure talk simply
smarter wireless
[Music]
if you're a business owner or leader
listen up financial wellness benefits
are no longer
quote unquote optional for your employee
benefits package
yeah financial wellness is a thing the
research team here at ramsey solutions
recently put out a report that found
that half of all employers say their
employees are stressed about money yet
only 18 percent feel responsible for
their employees financial well-being
well that didn't make sense your
employees bring their money stress
through the front door
with them because they come to work with
it
every
day
it's hurting your business with turnover
missed work lost productivity delayed
retirements you got to fix this team
to get our team's report on what's
happening in the workplace with
financial wellness and learn what the
employees are actually facing
you can add financial wellness to your
benefits package and will help your
business
text wellness to 33 789
wellness to 33789
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com they have a 100 satisfaction
guarantee that means even if you
mismeasure you pick the wrong color
they'll remake your blinds for free you
get free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use the promo code
ramsey to get the best possible
deal today's question comes from
jennifer in texas she writes and i'm 48
and i've been in an industry for 20
years that i'm not passionate about i've
done well but i'm burned out and feel
trapped i would love to go into nursing
am i crazy to quit my job to go into a
career where i'll make less than one
third of the income if i stick it out
for two to three years we could pay off
our house and i could just quit
completely but i'm not ready to retire
is the financial and emotional roi from
nursing school worth going back to
school or should i stick it out well
let's first address the fact that you
can work full-time while in nursing
school is it very very difficult yes but
you can do it you can certainly work
part-time
in health care even where you can get
some experience and more importantly
connections for nursing when you get out
of school so i when you know the reality
that you can still work that you can
cash flow your way through nursing
school here's what you can realize you
might be able to pay off the house in
two to three years while you're cash
flowing your way through nursing school
and if it's really about love i would
love to go into nursing so if you really
love the idea of caring for people in
that nursing profession you can make
really good money be very very fulfilled
for another 10 you know years 10 12
years based on your age so is it worth
it you have to answer that but i would
say it's worth it if you can cash flow
your way through
and not go into debt because you've
worked so hard
to get to a point where you're going to
pay off the house so sticking it out for
two to three years in a job you can't
stand i don't think you need to do that
i would make preparations to part-time
nursery school or if you can go full
time and make some other sacrifices i
think you go for it
i completely agree
completely agree and if the
you know her last question is the
financial and emotional roi from nursing
home school worth going back to school
yes without question you'll love your
work and you'll make good money yes and
you can pay off the house yeah yeah and
uh i don't think you have to stay in the
job i agree for two to three years and i
love the part-time idea so absolutely
so yeah the thing is this
you know but
make sure that you love
nursing
not you love the idea of it
very good and i and not you love um
the money you could make that's correct
so here's how you know that for those of
you who are looking at this question in
a different field or maybe even nursing
how do you do that so what she does is
she gets around other nurses this is
phone calls zooms coffees lunches and by
the way there's tons of different types
of nursing uh er
labor delivery checking people in at
surgery there's a lot of different
nursing positions and by talking to
you know as many nurses as you can in
all those different positions here's
what happens i get head knowledge they
tell me what it's like day in day out
what it's like to move into that
position how you advance you learn
everything and then what happens is your
brain processes that information dave
your heart eventually goes ding ding
ding or
and that's why it's so important to
really know what it is then your heart
will confirm and now you're ready to go
don't just assume you're gonna love it
joe's in louisville kentucky hi joe
welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
well my fiance and i
um she's not a u.s citizen
but she's lived here for
about eight years we plan to go back to
europe or move back to europe
for a year to two years while we do the
application process for
her permanent residency and i'm curious
if you think i should sell
my house or not
uh yeah yeah i would
it's a great time to sell a house
okay
and then if i do sell my house what
should i do with that extra money i
think i would
have somewhere between 80 and a hundred
thousand dollars you don't have any debt
we would
we have no debt uh which our our
finances are completely separated now
sure but we're um
but we have no debt neither one of us
other than the mortgage
and um
her family has a place for us to stay
for the time we're there so we would be
living rent free we both work remotely
okay so your incomes won't change
correct that's cool what do you all make
i make about a hundred thousand i'm
self-employed to engineering
and she is in marketing and makes around
50. excellent cool when are you getting
married
um
well that's that's a
big question we haven't planned all that
it'll probably be sometime in 2022
okay
all right
um
yeah i i i uh
i think i would as far as where you park
it
if you're gonna park it for
one year
probably just a money market account
you're not gonna make any money but
you're not gonna lose any money if
you're going to park it for two years or
more you may want to consider putting
part of that into some mutual funds
something like a
an index fund an s p 500 fund or
something like that i do some of that
but now i understand that that money
goes up and down and you could lose
a few thousand or you could make a few
thousand doing that
um sure you know you're not gonna lose
80 000 doing that but you might lose uh
eight
you know uh or something like that so
that you gotta if you want to play that
a little bit you could that's a medium
risk way to
take a chance of you know instead of
making eight dollars you might make
eight thousand dollars but
you're not gonna you're not gonna get
rich on any of this well it's just
sitting there as you're just parking it
until you're married and come back home
and so forth
so uh
obviously the citizenship thing changes
when you're married right
yes and the process is delayed due to
covid there's a big waiting list so
that's she hasn't seen her family in
quite a while so that's why we're
choosing to do that in europe we could
do that here but we kind of have to stay
put can't be in and out of the border
while that process has taken place
oh really
that's interesting
as far as we know yeah okay i don't i
don't know how it works honestly i'm
completely ignorant of that i just know
that when you're you marry an american
citizen it changes the process uh
substantially
uh and so
you know i i would guess that the sooner
the marriage happened the sooner the
citizenship would happen in other words
but i think i would want to know about
that uh
i heard that advice and i'm just sitting
there going what would i do in that
situation and because of the medium risk
factor
i'd probably park it in the money market
but i because that me going i i know
that it's going to sit there it's not
going to gain much at all but i know
it's there we're going to keep making
money keep adding to that so then when
we come back
yeah but i mean but there is a benefit i
mean the money you could make i guess
to me it felt like too risky for me yeah
for the
bulk of the time i've been on the air i
would have just said money market right
for that reason just don't worry about
it you know and because
uh but you know
in the last decade or so i've parked a
lot of money short term
[Music]
you know
and a time or two it's been down
i pulled out let cause i was gonna go
buy some real estate with it it was down
and i had lost a little bit a timer most
the time though it was up and i made a
lot yeah uh during the time it sat there
uh and so what i started realizing was
the risk wasn't that heavy it's not that
big it's not huge i mean eight thousand
dollars isn't gonna change his life
that's to make 150 000 between them yeah
you know so if you want to play with it
that's fine but if it's emotionally
going to keep you up at night then
certainly do the money market yeah
this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage j.c is with us hey jc
how are you i'm great how are you dave
better than i deserve welcome good to
have you
and where do you live indianapolis
indiana wow welcome to nashville and all
the way down here to do a debt-free
scream that is right love it how much
have you paid off i have paid off
nineteen thousand dollars or weight 19
188 dollars good how long did this take
um it took 14 months wow and your range
of income during that time i started out
at about 24 000
and bumped it up to a little over 36
000. good for you what do you do for a
living
monday through thursday i am a dental
assistant
and then um i have been a dog groomer
for the last seven years so i do that on
the weekends that's your side hustle
then mm-hmm okay very cool what kind of
debt was the 19 000
it was a endless cycle of credit cards
and then my student loan and my car hmm
how much did you owe on the student loan
in the car 3 500 on the student loan and
my car was 9 000. okay all right
and that i paid to my parents ah that
was a debt to my parents so it's good to
get rid of that too yeah that was a big
deal yeah i hear you i hear you so what
happened 14 months ago lit you on fire
girl you got after it yeah um well i
was working for a um
grooming salon and they had unexpectedly
just
closed the shop like so they told us
they were done and they were filing
bankruptcy and we were out of a job
so i was like man i have a lot of debt
like start of the year
i had a lot of debt i had lost my job
and so i uh
just decided to that it was time to
figure something else out i didn't
really want to work for anyone else in
that like grooming so
i started up my own thing
that was but you were already working
the dental
yeah at that time okay so you had that
job all along but that side job ended
yeah and that woke you up yeah because i
i really wasn't making too much money at
the dentist job
like
i can make a bunch of money just
grooming so that was where i really
made a lot of my money okay all right
wow good for you
well congratulations and how did you get
connected to us
parents have listened to you guys for a
while and i they'd mention some things
about you and
they've always said you know
i'm really not been one to be super
responsible with money more of a free
spirit
so
i wanted to kind of prove to them that i
could really stick to something and and
you know get it done and especially when
it came to my finances so
they knew that i had been
in credit card debt for a long time and
i just
it would come the start of the year my
tax return would come and it'd all go to
my credit card debt
so i was done doing that
so what did you do you started listening
to youtube or watching youtube podcasts
on spotify broadcast every day to and
from work every day okay got real
serious about it
and that gave you everything you needed
to do this it sure did yeah so you
didn't have the books or anything from
your paper
no but i did end up going to the
bookstore and i found one of your older
books the total money makeover
and i started reading that um and then i
decided to sign up for the fpu class oh
okay and uh i was like man 100 should i
spend that like it could go to my debt
i'm like ramsay said just do it
so i did the fpu class and it was
definitely worth it
it was a little difficult because it was
online during covid yeah so um i did the
best i could with my three-year-old
running around um so but but it was
still fine and worth it i mean i stuck
to it good for you i'm proud of you i
bet your mom and dad are they sure are
they really are they were cheering you
along yeah
it was it was a big deal for christmas
instead of getting a bunch of presents i
saved up two thousand dollars and gave
it to them to put towards my car wow
and uh that meant a lot to them they
really were not expecting it at all
and so to see them you know hear them
talking about how proud of me they were
and you know
just the hug from my dad and the pat on
my back and you know it just it got me
fired up to finish paying off the rest
so that's cool yeah wow very cool you
jumped from 24 000 to 36. and i'm
guessing here is that some overtime but
also a lot of dog grooming
a lot of weekends yes without the little
man i mean i miss him a lot the hardest
part was being away from him that much i
mean it was monday through thursday full
time at the dentist job
and then thursday night into sunday i
was grooming like every single weekend
what kept you going
he did that's beautiful right there my
three-year-old that's beautiful yeah and
um i have
the greatest accountability partner
which is the doctor i work for tony um
every day and he knew how much this
meant to me um every day he'd come in
and we would be talking about the
weekend how many dogs you have to groom
this weekend how busy you gonna be how
much money you gonna make and it just
was like
you got to stick to it you know
a lot of my time went to that and now i
can say it's worth it now you're free
yeah
how's it
feel i can breathe
that's that's how it feels i can breathe
finally how old are you 26 26 years old
and you've never been debt-free as an
adult have you no
no it was almost like having a credit
card was a competition how much did you
get approved for you know my credit
limit's 4 000. what's yours
that was like my 21 year old mindset
yeah yeah so got you in trouble uh-huh
wow
yeah you have to feel
uh one lady said accomplished
i mean this was a not just a 19 000 debt
paid off you changed i did
i've changed so much through this whole
experience i mean i really thank you so
much for this i i don't know how
to say it but it's just it's been so
eye-opening like i can
raise him without having to worry you
know
all my money's going to my debt and not
to what i could be doing more for him
you know
i've got his savings fund for his
college started i've got my retirement
fund going thanks to thanks to tony
you know he he's really helped me out
too he's it's awesome coached you alone
yeah that is just so cool
well well done well done jc and your
young man's name and age you want to get
him in the shot for the debt free scream
his name is cyprus and he is three you
want to come up here
come up with mom while we do your
debt-free scream she's worked her tail
end off she's a hero
she's changed her whole life man i'm so
proud of you
so powerful so well done good stuff
all right it's jc and cyprus from
indianapolis man 19 000
paid off in 14 months making 24
to 36. uh we are looking at some people
who have changed their lives i'm so
proud of you got a copy of the uh
legacy journey for you that's the next
chapter for you to become wealthy now
unbelievably and you are on your way i'm
so proud of you and a copy of the total
money makeover so you can give it away
to somebody awesome so we'll give you
one of each you ready all right jc and
cypress count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three
two
one i'm debt free
[Applause]
oh man
[Applause]
that 19 000 when you're making 24
to 36. it's getting with it
that's
that's more than some doc calling in
here paying off 190 grand yeah i mean
that's incredible yeah what she pulled
off there
was absolutely incredible yeah and she
is i mean the and the difference in
weight on her
after that the actual math the the
freedom in her math now is just
it's just amazing
she is in really really good shape and
you can see what you guys can't see in
the radio you can hear hints of it in
her voice but what you can see is on her
face yeah
her countenance yeah
you can see the sense of uh
she's a young warrior yeah another
single mom
behind the eight ball and yet she said
enough and she did it that's getting
with it folks 19 000 14 months with a
heavy heart
upped her eyeballs and dog fur
she did it
she did it
well that's exactly how that is
yeah there's a great place to go when
you're broke don't work that's right i
love it
this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today ii corinthians 9 8
and god is able to bless you abundantly
so then all things at all times having
all that you need you will abound in
every good work
winston churchill said the pessimist
sees difficulty in every opportunity the
optimist sees opportunity
in every difficulty
my fico score
is zero
i don't have a fico score
it's undeterminable that's what they
call it
sounds kind of evil but yeah i'm
undeterminable so how do i survive how
do i make it
i pay for things
and if i don't pay for them i don't buy
them
now i know that's weird
but it's a it's a it's a freeing concept
keeps you out of debt you can teach your
children to be counter cultural
in a culture that has lost its
and we've just dropped prices up to 80
on our best-selling kids products so you
can have fun
and have an educational summer the
adventure pack is a family favorite that
includes the new story time collection
financial piece junior
the smart saver bank
and more to make learning about money
actually fun the best part is you can
add an extra kit for each sibling or if
you've got a teen the teen entrepreneur
toolbox
by anthony o'neill is the perfect safe
and flexible way for them to create
their own summer job
teach kids the right way to handle money
while they're young that way they won't
live in their bait your basement when
they're 30. save up to 80 percent off by
shopping the kids and teens sale online
at ramsey ramseysolutions.com
store ramseysolutions.com
store
tina is with us in phoenix hi tina
welcome to the ramsay show
hi jake hi ken how are you guys doing
great how can we help yes so i've talked
to ken last week and i wanted to thank
you ken for your advice
well that's awesome what would you do
so i i was not getting a recommendation
from my boss and your advice was to
flood the potential employers in box
with references that could speak of my
character and so
with it being a long weekend i did that
today and after a couple of years came
through they said they would like to
speak with me
and it as long as everything goes
through tomorrow i'm going to meet with
the teachers and that goes smoothly then
i will have a job and they said they
were very understanding of that
sometimes relationships just don't match
and but they're willing to give me a
chance oh i remember this so tina i want
to tell dave what happened so tina had
great references from previous teaching
positions but had a personality conflict
with the principal at the school that
she just left she was worried that
because they wanted to hire this new
school wanted to hire but that one uh
leader wouldn't give her a
recommendation and so i told her well do
you have a lot of other relationships in
the school system that can vouch for how
great you are and that this was kind of
a an outlying circumstances so she went
and did it and uh looks like she's going
to get that opportunity so good for you
teen a way to not quit you did that
you're the one that went out there and
believed that you had a reputation uh
worth sharing and uh that's really
awesome very cool tina
yeah i thank you guys for the advice i
really appreciate it so i just wanted to
say thanks it worked yeah thank you
you did it you went out and fought for
it fight for things folks yeah but you
know what you told her she could and
exactly what to do and she just executed
she went and did it yeah and you know
sometimes we tell people what to do and
they go home and don't do it you know
that's right like too often um and then
they call us two years later i should
have done it
uh but then then other times it's that's
that's why we come down here is people
like her that's exactly right you say go
do this and you'll start winning and she
goes does that and then she starts
winning that's pretty cool it's fun got
the job got the job the ken coleman job
technique there it is
i love it that is absolutely fabulous
amy is in sacramento hi amy welcome to
the ramsey show
hi thank you so much for having me on
sure what's up
um all right so i started a business
last year while i was laid off um and
then i got called back to work right as
i was about to start looking for clients
i'm really eager to quit at least by
april of 2022 and focus on my business
full-time
it's a bookkeeping business if i didn't
mention that
and um we already have six months worth
of an emergency fund saved up we plan on
having an additional twelve thousand
dollars by next april the thing is my
husband has a job where he gets laid off
quite often he's in a labor union
um so we would only be able to last
about five and a half months on that
extra 12k
if my husband were to get laid off
otherwise how long how often is he laid
off for five and a half months
i mean he was like in the last two years
he was laid off once for six months
um other than that i would say usually
like maybe three four months on average
man this job sucks yeah i'd be getting
out of the union it does suck but we're
waiting until he gets his journeyman
card because then you can quit and you
can take that anywhere you can work for
the city or something like that yeah
we're in it for the long game
unfortunately
yeah okay so how long before he gets the
tournament
card um so i think it'll be probably
another like three or four years
wow
you're tolerating a lot of crap for that
hours you know so every time he gets
laid off he doesn't get hours um
but anyways so if he gets laid off we
could last on on that extra 12 000 for
about five and a half months um
otherwise we'd have to dig into the
six-month emergency fund or i'd have to
get a job again
um what do you think about that am i
crazy for wanting to quit when i what is
i mean you're assuming your business
makes nothing
i mean i don't i just don't want to
estimate that i mean is your business
not made any money all right
i mean right now i have two monthly
clients i'm netting
aside from like clean up work that's one
time project um i'm only netting like
300 a month obviously going you don't
have a business yet you got a glorified
hobby
right well the reason why i want to quit
and go full time is because i'm still
like learning the business and i want to
focus my attention a hundred percent
wrong way you got to flip that you got
to keep doing these side side jobs like
this let's get that up to 900 a month
and then let's get it to 1500 a month
and let's see how many hours we can
actually give to it and really really
hustle and grow your credibility based
on your experience but you don't go all
in um
yeah you get experience then you build
it up
okay so
what if i were to take a part-time job
with the full-time job no your part-time
job is learning this side hustle that's
right and growing this side hustle
that's correct no this listen you cannot
justify
giving up your whole career and giving
up everything and walking into something
that's 300 freaking dollars a month you
have got to prove this i mean not right
now i know it's right now so prove me
wrong go make some dadgum money
you do whatever you want to do kiddo but
i'm telling you that's dumb don't do
that yeah okay yeah let's incrementally
let's get let's go from two clients to
three or four clients or let's let's
drop the two clients replace them with
with more work from clients that'll give
you more work we want to get your
billable as a bookkeeper this is all
about your billable time what you have
is a theory right now yeah you need to
move it from theory to business
a business is something that makes money
ongoing that is substantial that you can
live on
you need to grow a business
and as the business gets up close to
what you're making now then you quit
your full time but you will have proven
your ability to make money doing this
you have to do that and you've got this
dream in your head that if you just go
full time it's all going to work out
honey it's not how it works because you
haven't figured out how to run this
dadgum business yet you haven't figured
out how to make money with it and you
got to go make some money that's the
whole goal here everybody's willing to
do what it takes
very few are willing to wait as long as
it takes and that's where you are the
tension for you right now is you don't
want to wait because you really love
this bookkeeping and you get this day
job you want to get rid of here's the
problem you're not ready your day job's
going to fund the dream job go build the
side business
build it get the doc get the boat closer
to the dock don't be jumping in the
water thinking you're hitting the boat
the boat's way out there still yeah you
need to get it up closer so you can land
in the boat when you jump
please
please do that
that puts this hour of the ramsay show
in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section or head to
theramsi show.com thanks for listening
[Music]
you